السلام عليكم ورحمه الله هذا موجز الاخبار
من الجزيره اتهام وزير الخارجيه الصينيه
تيم جانجا لم يسميها بتخريب جهود تعزيز
السلام لانهاء الحرب في اوكرانيا وقال
الوزير الصيني ان بلاده لا تزود اي طرف
بالاسلحه في الازمه الاوكرانيه التي اكد
انه يمكن تجنبها بتغليب التهدئه على
التصعيد واضاف ان جهه ما تشجع تصعيد
الصراع وتستخدم الوضع في اوكرانيا لتحقيق
اهداف جيروس سياسيه معينه وشدد على ان
العلاقات الصينيه الروسيه غير منحازه ولا
تستهدف اي طرف ثالث
قال الرئيس الاوكراني انه طلب من القاده
العسكريين ايجاد القوات المناسبه لمساعده
المقاتلين في مدينه
واضاف انه لا يوجد جزء من اوكرانيا يمكن
التخلي عنه
وكان وزير الدفاع الامريكي قد قال ان قيمه
مدينه بخموت رمزيه اكثر منها استراتيجيه
او عمليه
اقتحم عشرات المستوطنين بلده حوارها ليله
الماضيه تحت حمايه جيش الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي وافاد شهود عيان ان المستوطنين
اطلقوا الرصاص الحيه في الهواء وافاد
مراسل الجزيره من الشبان الفلسطينيين
اصيبوا بحالات اختناق جراء قنابل الغاز
التي القتها قوه الاحتلال هذا وهدم
السلطات الاحتلال تسعه منازل سكنيه بزعن
بنائها دون ترخيص في القدس الشرقيه
والخليل واريحا في الضفه الغربيه
هذا وطلب وزير الامن القومي الاسرائيلي
ايتامر بنجفير باستمرار هدم منازل
الفلسطينيين في القدس حتى خلال شهر رمضان
المبارك
قال المدير العام للوكاله الدوليه للطاقه
الذريه الى طهران وافقت على السماح
للوكاله بالمضي في اجراءات المراقبه
والتحقق الاضافيه واضاف ان هناك فرصه
جنديه فيما يتعلق بايران
من جهته قلل المتحدث باسم وزاره الخارجيه
الايرانيه الى طهران تواصلت مع الوكاله
الى تفاهمات بعد زياره جروس الاخيره ويمكن
ان تمهد لحل القضايا العالقه
يتوجه وزير الشؤون الاستراتيجيه
الاسرائيليه لواشنطن في زياره رسميه لبحث
قضايا ابرزها الملف الايراني والقضيه
الفلسطينيه بعد التصعيد الاخير في الضفه
الغربيه
من جانبه قال وزير الدفاع الايراني ان
تهديدات اسرائيل ليست سوى اوهام وان طهران
سوف ترد عليها متى وحيثما رات ذلك ضروريا
اعرب المتحدث باسم الخارجيه الامريكيه عن
قلق بلاده من تصريحات الرئيس التونسي بشان
المهاجرين الافارقه وحملات الاعتقال التي
استهدفتهم ودعى السلطات التونسيه الى
التنسيق مع المنظمات الدوليه بشان العوده
الامنه والطوعيه للمهاجرين الراغبين في
الرجوع الى بلدانهم
من جهه اعرب المتحدث باسم الامين العام
للامم المتحده عن ادانه المنظمه الدوليه
خطاب العنصريه والكراهيه والقمع ضد
الاجانب
الى ذلك علق البنك الدولي واطلاق
الاستراتيجيه الخاصه بتونس وقال رئيس
البنك ان البنك اوقف عمله مع تونس بعد
تصريحات الرئيس قيس سعيد بشان المهاجرين
وقد اتهم وزير الخارجيه التونسيه تراف
داخليه وخارجيه رفض تسميتها بافتعال
وتاجيج ما وصفها بالحمله التي تستهدف
بلاده
اشكركم على متابعه الموجه زلمة كنتم
توقعتكم بكل خير